Vasco, from Portugal, asks:
In a world where we already have Google and other search engines,
what are the advantages of building another search engine?
So certainly, you don't want to try to duplicate something
that behaves exactly like Google does,
because Google works pretty well at what it does.
But there are lots of things you can do that would be
different from what Google does.
One of the best examples of that is the search engine called DuckDuckGo,
and we had a visit from Gabriel Weinberg a few weeks ago.
There's a video, with a few clips from that visit,
where he talks about what motivated him to build DuckDuckGo.
There''ll be a few more clips of that later in this course
where you'll get some idea of the kinds of things
that he thought were interesting to make a new search engine,
and why he was motivated to build one.
But there are lots of things that you can think about that would be
new features that are different from what Google does--
or specializing your search engine for a particular kind of
corpus that you're searching for.
Probably, you don't want to try to build a generic Web search engine, like Google,
unless you've got some ideas how to go beyond that or
to do things differently, that would be more interesting.